from a Divine test involving a corpse to
the bizarre Musical Battle that unfolded
during The Siege here's everything Waco
American apocalypse doesn't tell you
about the real story
the notoriously charismatic and
manipulative David koresh would
eventually convince his followers that
he was the son of God incarnate quresh
was born Vernon Wayne Howell in 1959 to
a 14 year old mother early in his young
life his mother married an abusive
ex-convict adding to his troubled early
life as a dyslexic child he struggled in
school handles mercilessly bullied but
despite these challenges his mother
described him as an inquisitive little
boy who serves for knowledge led him to
dissect everything from truck engines to
the Bible former Branch Davidian David
buns who first met quresh in 1981
described him as a Drifter who appeared
obviously poor and lost additionally
when writer Jeff Gwen came across the
path of the branch of Davidians a
doomsday focused offshoot of the Seventh
Day Adventist he described quresh as a
stuttering stammering 21 year old who is
barely coherent but soon however the
theologically gifted quresh began to
gradually position himself as their
leader
one story that gets left out of nearly
every Waco documentary is the bizarre
tale of a resurrection doll that
transpired during qureshia's rise to
power as the documentary notes qurashi's
Ascension was aided by his relationship
with the Branch Davidians Prophet Lois
Rodin Rodin was several decades his
senior at the time of their Affair when
Rodin died leaving a power vacuum koresh
found himself firing against the late
Leader's son George for control of the
cult in 1986 George Rodin dug up long
buried church member Anna Hughes corpse
for the purpose of challenging caresh to
a Divine test according to Rodin whoever
could resurrect her would be the group's
next Prophet but rather than dabbling in
the zombie Arts correct thought of an
easier way to ascend the throne getting
Rodin arrested for the desecration of a
corpse when the sheriff told qurash to
produce a photo of the corpse in
question he and AIDS camo clad followers
conducted what the New York Times
described as a commando-style raid on
the compound this led to the shootout
briefly mentioned in Waco American
apocalypse after a mistrial for
attempted murder koresh ultimately took
control of the compound
as portrayed in the series The Davidians
tried to present a picture of familial
love although some abuse as mentioned in
the series or the Waco children suffered
immensely Joanne vallega who was six
years old when she lost both parents on
The Siege compared life to Waco to
prison the group lived ostea lives
without Plumbing electricity heat or air
conditioning koresh meanwhile made sure
he had air conditioning in the brutal
Texas heat furthermore koresh dictated
every aspect of their lives women's
appearances were strictly regulated
members attended Bible study three times
a day and food was strictly controlled
doctors were also forbidden for brunch
Davidian children serious discipline
began at only six months old among the
countless miseries Davidian kids were
forced to endure with severe beatings
from a paddle called the helper as well
as constant verbal humiliation while
girls as young as 11 were sexually
abused by quresh boys are forced through
military drills one girl was even locked
up in a small room and forced to eat
from a bowl in the floor for months like
any motivated cult leader koresh was
committed to expanding his fan base so
this meant recruitment trips abroad to
Australia the United Kingdom and Israel
as Millennials part of the Branch
Davidian belief system is that God will
gather his faithful in Israel for the
final battle between good and evil
according to religion scholar James D
Tabor koresh and his followers believed
they would fight beside the people of
Israel in this final apocalyptic
Showdown it was an Israel that koresh
received an apparent message convincing
him that he was the Lamb of God and
should change his name to spread the
message quresh even had business cards
made declaring that he was the Messiah
well you know what they think of me they
think I'm the son of God do they yeah
Rabbi Abraham pellid encountered quresh
using his guitar to attract new
followers on an Israel recruiting
Mission according to palette quresh
would stand on the street singing
religious music then lornu recruits to
Mount Carmel with the promise of
music-related work and free plane
tickets as a rabbi concerned with Cults
preying on locals pellet got to know
karesh and his new recruits for the
hopes of turning them away after
dissuading a few of them pelid reached
out to Israel's minister of interior to
report his concerns a Ministry responded
by informing quresh that his Visa had
expired and it was time to go
far too many sources emphasize the
alleged peacefulness of the Branch
Davidians or their gun ownership as an
investment while Waco American
apocalypse doesn't play into this Mythos
the series doesn't quite manage to
convey the level of training the group
had in anticipation of that apocalypse
either Kiri Jewel who escaped the
compound before the Waco Siege after her
father won custody from her mother told
ABC he always said that they would come
for us and we were going to defend
ourselves and we were all gonna die
according to Jewel the children were
raised to believe this so firmly that
she was convinced she wouldn't live past
the age of 12. in the Branch Davidian
belief system the federal government and
the outside world were the prophesized
Agents of Babylon an evil force bent on
destroying True Believers and the
Messiah everyone who lived in the
compounds had been trained for the
prophesized Warfare and their neighbors
often reported hearing gunshots coming
from Mount Carmel despite their training
and belief that death would be necessary
many were not prepared for the reality
of this commitment I'm talking to you
somebody's gonna get hurt during the
1970s quresh was interested in playing
rock music as he became more involved in
religion he never abandoned his love of
Music quresh even named one of his
guitars the Psalms 45 guitar comparing
it to the Song of Solomon according to
Clive Doyle one of the few Branch
Davidians to survive the siege music was
one of the tools koresh used to bring in
new followers in 1994 a former
acquaintance of qurash even produced an
album of his music titled voice of fire
in their efforts to force a davidian's
house the FBI began blasting a playlist
of strange sounds and music that
included animal noises bringing phones
Tibetan chants Christmas carols and
Nancy Sinatra in an almost comical
moment in an otherwise dark tale
correction his Pals hit back with their
own music according to hostage
negotiator RJ Craig the impromptu Battle
of the Bands lasted for hours
the nature of the fire that burned down
the Mount Carmel compounds has been the
subject of countless conspiracy theories
in the years to follow many conspiracy
theorists claim the U.S government
intentionally Set Fire To The Compound
possibly using tanks mounted with
flamethrowers to do it and then there's
a slightly less nefarious theory that
the tear gas canisters use in the final
push might have interacted with the
Davidians gas lanterns to create fires
all over the complex contradicting these
claims is the fact that the pyrotechnic
canisters use in the operation but fired
six hours before the Blazers started
however as emphasized in the Netflix
documentary no Davidians fled the
building when these fires erupted a
panel of arson investigators later
concluded that the Davidians started
Three Fires across a compound their
conclusion was based partly on the fact
that the fires were started
simultaneously and that accelerants like
lighter fluid were detected in the
aftermath surviving cult member Clive
Doyle who tearfully claimed the
Davidians did not start the fires was
found wearing a jacket soaked in
tolerance several of the children's
bodies recovered were also found to have
died from gunshots and to stabbing due
to the fire these children were
unreachable during the compound's final
moments and would have been killed by
their parents or other Branch Davidians
further evidence of the adult cultists
choose death by Suicide
one of the more controversial aspects of
the Waco Siege centers around attorney
general Janet Reno's involvement as
recounted in the Netflix series Reno had
recently been sworn in making Waco one
of the first major tests she would face
in office when it became clear that
quresh had no intention to surrender FBI
HRT Commander dick Rogers flew to
Washington to meet with Reno and make
the case for tear gas use in the final
episode journalist Lee Hancock
emphasized what Rogers chose to reveal
to Reno during this briefing according
to Hancock Rogers showed Reno claims of
child abuse from former Davidians
however he omitted the video recorded
during the siege that showed quresh and
the children in the compound the FBI
leadership in Waco recognized
that these videos made Chris look pretty
good this idea that we know unilaterally
ordered tear gas in response to
exaggerated abuse claims was a common
sentiment on the Waco aftermath but it
grossly oversimplifies Reno's decision
although the justice department report
would later say there wasn't explicit
evidence children at the compounds were
being physically or sexually abused the
report also concluded that the FBI did
not exaggerate the claims that were
presented or sell the idea of tear gas
Torino instead she and her advisors
considered a number of complex issues
including the rapidly deteriorating
conditions inside the compound while
weighing the possible outcomes of tear
gas use and other options tragically she
wasn't briefed on the davidian's
commitment to die rather than surrender
based on his doomsday prophecies and the
previous shoot sales at Mount Carmel it
was likely only a matter of time before
David koresh brought violence upon his
followers nonetheless the long string of
mistakes and miscalculations made by
federal and local officials made the
final bloodbath a foregone conclusion
reflecting on these events in a recent
interview series director to the Russell
emphasized that the FBI was dealing with
a completely new scenario in terms of
scale intensity and duration under such
circumstances the potential for serious
mistakes to be made is significant
fortunately those mistakes led to
Serious reforms in both the ATF and FBI
agent Byron Sage cited poor
communication between the Tactical and
hostage negotiation teams as one of the
key problems during the Waco Siege it's
something they've worked to correct
moving forward the ATF also has
standardized as training across Special
Response teams while expanding its
instruction in warrant execution hostage
management and several other areas
likewise FBI has worked to increase
training and cohesion today it trains
hostage negotiation and tactical units
together the organization has also
established a critical incident Response
Group for overseeing these operations
just as several surviving members of the
heavens gate codes are still out there
spreading Marshall applewhite's message
long after their fellow acolytes exited
the Earthly plane David carrester has a
small handful of Believers Kathy
Schroeder who narrowly survived the
final showdown by getting arrested when
she came out to see her son made no
effort to hide her in drawing loyalty to
koresh in the Netflix series in the
documentary she provides a jarring
glimpse into the Davidians Twisted world
view or describing sex with quresh as a
religious experience the whole time we
were having sex
it was a Bible study she also insists
that quresh wasn't a pedophile because
his victims were adults in their belief
system Resurrection is a key part of the
Davidians belief system and it's
something that survivors who lost loved
ones in The Siege cling to some of the
survivors believe that koresh is
currently in a state of Soul sleep and
will be resurrected during the
ceremonial Harvest if you or anyone you
know has been a victim of sexual assault
help is available visit the rape abuse
and incest national network websites or
contact Reigns National helpline that's
1-800-656-hope 4673
[Music]